here's my ultimate healthy lunch faster
cook but crammed with flavor a delicious
saffron flatbread with mussels it
doesn't get any healthier than their
first job the super easy
saffron flatbread
[Music]
put the saffron into the bowl and a
couple of teaspoons of hot water that
starts to infuse the saffron and so you
can maximise on the color across your
flat beds to make the dough simply add
plain flour a pinch of salt and pepper
to a bowl and then pour in a dash of
olive oil that makes the dough nice and
silky and rich your saffron water you'll
see how concentrated it is now and then
you'll need cold water then simply need
to bring the dough together mop up all
your flour you can see now cephalus
activated it's got that really nice
color beautiful use your wrist
we'll just need it nicely will do now is
smoothing out the gluten strands push
run tuck in push and tuck in and each
every time you do this getting softer
you just sort of form at this perfect
beautiful don't it's smells delicious
that saffron is very powerful
now sit that in your bowl cover with
cling film let it rest for 10 to 15
minutes this relaxes the dough making it
easier to rob and gives it time to
infuse with the saffron I cut that into
three and then roll the nice and thinly
now
lightly flour surface and then just
bring that it's like a perfect ball on
the board
was a glass ball you're rolling pin and
just roll it out now it doesn't get any
simpler than that just lightly flour
that on top a little salt cooking the
flatbread is easy just pop in a hot dry
pan and they're ready in minutes as it
hits the pan it starts the blister ready
for turning beautiful - the color on
there now you want it nice and crisp
almost blistering on both sides because
it's nice and thin it's cooked once
browned on both sides just cool on a
rack flat breads done now on to the
mussels have a secret a high in cooking
great mussels is in the speed you cook
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start cooking
first thing pancetta
I want it quite chunky if you can't get
pancetta I always like to use a sort of
streaky bacon because I want to sort of
Rendell that flavor
now the streaky bacon now tomatoes
garlic and chili cherry tomatoes they're
just going in whole the garlic just
crush the garlic it's all that flavor
comes out chili I want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked
don't touch of olive oil pancetta in
pancetta takes moments once it's brown
and crisp put your garlic chili and
whole cherry tomatoes into the pan and
I'm using dry sherry I think it works
better in this recipe than white wine
which is classically used at this stage
then oregano finely chopped stalks on
all I'll go on and then just give that a
little mix and see those muscles start
to open lid goes on you got to lock in
that flavor gotta lock in that heat the
muscles will take four to five minutes
to steam in the meantime cut your flat
breads into strips crispy and crunchy
now the muscles
Wow that is incredible my goodness me
[Music]
now as one lunch I definitely don't want
to miss healthy and delicious doesn't
get any better than that
steamed mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
[Music]